Hey Thoughty2 here.
In 1919 a young ambitious 30-year-old stood
in a beer hall in Munich, Germany and gave
a passionate speech about politics to 111
attendees.
Only four months later, the same young man
gave another speech, but this time, due to
word of mouth, his audience had grown to over
2000.
A few months later he gives another speech
with 6,000 devotees in attendance.
This is how revolutions begin.
That ambitious young man went on to change
the world beyond recognition, by committing
countless atrocities against the human race
and attempting genocide.
Yes I am talking about Adolf Hitler.
Do not take my words as praise, but there
is no doubt that Hitler’s oration abilities
are unrivalled throughout history.
His ability to persuade others and bring them
into his cause and align their ideals with
his own were powerful beyond belief.
During one 2 hour speech in 1920 he was completely
interrupted 58 times by thundering applause
and cheers from the crowd.
But was Adolf Hitler a great leader?
Absolutely not, effective maybe, but great,
no.
As humans with a conscience we define great
as doing good, therefore a great leader must
use their power and influence for good, not
evil as Hitler did.
But besides the obvious deplorable reasons
that Hitler was not a great leader, he wasn’t
actually good at leading.
Let me explain, Hitler was a fantastic orator,
he gave speeches so powerful, so intense that
they made you forget your morals and follow
him into a genocidal abyss.
He was extremely effective at collecting followers
and power.
But being able to rally hearts and minds is
only one half of being a great leader.
For, once Hitler had that power, he was hopeless
at putting it to use, at least when you compare
him to his wartime competition.
A truly great leader in Hitler’s position
of immense power would have leveraged Germany’s
strengths and turned wartime Germany into
a true superpower, a force to be reckoned
with.
And a true leader could of done so without
ever going to war, using only diplomacy and
leverage.
There were many years leading up to the war
when a great leader could have turned Germany
into the modern world’s first superpower
giving Germany a far better chance of winning
the war or better yet, bypassing it altogether.
But Hitler was too consumed by his own hate
and pride.
His deep hatred of Jews, communists and others
caused him to get distracted by and drawn
into many futile conflicts that were completely
unnecessary and only hindered Germany’s
overall strength, such as Stalingrad.
He was more concerned with destroying his
neighboroughing countries than focusing on
the strengths of his own, Germany.
These are certainly not the traits of a great
leader, just a passionate, angry fool.
Are you passionate about something, but tired
of feeling like a fool?
I’d like to take a minute to thank Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes in design, business,
technology and more.
Premium membership gives you unlimited access
to high quality classe on must-know topics,
so you can improve your skills, unlock new
opportunities, and do the work you love.
If you’re thinking of starting a business
or want to start a new project with other
people then you’ll need to become a great
leader yourself.
Some of the greatest leaders in history have
also been the greatest orators, Barack Obama,
Winston Churchill, Martin Luther King.
To sharpen up your public speaking skills
I can’t recommend highly enough the Skillshare
course “Presentation Essentials: How to
Share Ideas That Inspire Action”.
And good news, if you’re one of the first
1000 people to use the promo link in the description
you will get your first 2 months of Skillshare
Premium for just 99 cents.
After that Skillshare is more affordable than
most learning platforms out there at only
$10 a month.
Click the link in the description to check
out Simon Sinek’s course and thousands of
others, but remember, only the first 1000
people will get 2 months for 99 cents.
Hitler’s wartime enemy Winston Churchill
is also thought of as one of history’s most
powerful leaders, but unlike Hitler, many
people go as far as to call Churchill a great
leader.
So what’s the difference?
Is Churchill only a great leader, and Hitler
is not because Churchill was fighting for
good, not evil?
Well that certainly helps, but it’s the
reason why Churchill was fighting for good
which made him a truly great leader.
And that reason is a great empathy for his
people.
Hitler’s motivation for going to war was
occupation of neighbouring countries to expand
the German empire and his idea of a “pure
race” and also genocide, these are selfish
reasons, Hitler’s powerful oration may have
tricked millions into believing that he had
the German people’s best interests in mind,
but in truth his motivations were not only
selfish, but driven by delusions, insecurity
and mental insanity.
Churchill’s motivations were the polar-opposite,
he went to war to defend his people and his
country from the tyranny of evil, he had no
desire to invade and capture other lands or
to enslave and murder innocent people.
Psychologists have long studied what it takes
to be a great leader and they have all converged
on one key quality that every great leader
from history shared.
One mental attribute that separates Churchill
from Hitler, emotional intelligence.
It is not intellect, cunning or physical prowess
that makes a great leader, it is emotional
intelligence.
That is the ability to sympathise with others,
to know how people think, behave and how they
will react given any situation.
What made Abraham Lincoln such a great leader?
Such an icon, respected throughout the ages.
How was he able to overcome the tremendous
challenges in abolishing slavery?
He possessed more emotional intelligence than
his enemies.
Whilst the plantation owners and leaders of
the confederacy were only concerned with monetary
gain from their slaves.
Lincoln was able to sympathise with the plight
of the slaves, he could humanise them and
this gave him the drive, the passion, the
motivation to put every fibre of himself into
his quest to set them free, and that he did.
Hitler may have been an extremely intelligent
man, an incredible orator and powerfully persuasive,
but he had not a scrap of emotional intelligence,
he had no sympathy.
No man who did the things he did could possess
these qualities.
But Churchill, despite his image as a pragmatic
bulldog, did and that’s why he led Britain
and the World to victory.
But being a great leader isn’t just being
able to make the correct decision.
A truly great leader must also be able to
make the hardest decision of all, when it
is most needed of them.
No matter the cost.
On 10th May 1940 Winston Churchill was appointed
Prime Minister of Great Britain.
On the very same day, Hitler launched a huge
invasion of France.
occupying vast swathes of the country.
Before long Hitler’s army had occupied Paris
and forced the nation of France to surrender.
When Churchill heard that France was prepared
to surrender and make a peace deal with Hitler
he knew that if the Nazis were to get their
hands on France’s navy, which at the time
was the second most powerful in the world,
after Britain’s, then Britain would be screwed.
Sure, Britain’s navy was powerful, but with
the combined might of France’s Navy and
Germany’s U-boats, Britain would have been
Hitler’s for the taking, and worse yet,
if Hitler took Britain, and its navy, the
rest of the world would have stood no chance
against the spread of Hitler’s tyranny.
with all that combined military might, he
could have taken the US with ease and today
the world would be under Nazi rule, simply
because Hitler got his hands on a few French
warships.
Churchill could absolutely not let this happen.
Initially he wrote to the US president FDR
and asked if he could borrow fifty of their
older warships to defend Britain in the event
that Hitler took France’s navy, but FDR
was too concerned with winning the upcoming
election and so denied Churchill’s request,
even after Churchill wrote back to him explaining
that if Britain was taken then America would
be next.
The French Admiral had made a promise to Churchill
that if the Nazis did ever try to take France’s
warships then the French would sabotage their
own ships rendering them useless to Hitler.
But Churchill was too pragmatic to rely solely
on the French disabling their own ships and
so he formulated a grand plan called operation
Catapult.
The most daring and most morally difficult
plan that Churchill had so far enacted.
France’s vast navy was spread out in fleets
around the globe, so Churchill planned to
use espionage, stealth and if necessary force
to capture all of France’s warships and
relocate them to British waters.
So, on the 3rd July 1940 operation Catapult
was launched and simultaneous takeovers of
every French naval vessel took place within
a few hours around the globe.
Bearing in mind that until now, France was
Britain’s closest ally during the war, this
must have been a horrendously difficult decision
for Churchill to make, but the decision that
he had to make in just a few hour’s time
would be many times more difficult, in fact
it would arguably be the most difficult, the
most heart-wrenching decision the Prime Minister
would make his entire life.
A decision that many historians have since
said was one of the biggest turning points
of the war and changed the fate of the World.
You see, all but one of the fleets within
the French navy could be taken with little
effort by simply sneaking British servicemen
onboard and putting a gun up to the captain.
But one fleet, the strongest and most heavily
guarded within France’s navy would not be
so simple.
In the harbour of Mers-el-Kébir in French
Algeria, France had moored their four largest
and most powerful ships, the Bretagne, Provence,
Strasbourg and Dunkerque, as well as some
smaller destroyers.
If Hitler got his hands on just this fleet
alone it would spell the end of the war for
Britain and the world.
Churchill wrote an ultimatum to the French
admiral and sent out a fleet of the Royal
Navy’s most powerful vessels to deliver
it to the French fleet at Mers-el-Kebir.
It gave France just six hours from receiving
the letter to sail their large fleet of warships
to Britain or America and surrender them or
the British Navy will regrettably sink them
using force.
The Royal Navy surrounded the French fleet
and a long, intense standoff wore on for many
hours as the French Admiral refused to peacefully
surrender his ships to the British, their
allies.
The French admiral was annoyed that Churchill
obviously didn’t trust his promise that
the French navy would destroy their own ships
if the Nazis tried to take them, he was also
annoyed that a lower ranking member of the
Royal Navy was sent to deliver Churchill’s
ultimatum to him, instead of someone higher
up in the command.
He also didn’t believe that the British
would actually fire upon them if they refused
to hand over their ships.
So with the French Admiral remaining stubborn
the two supposedly allied nations, stood gun
to gun across the harbour in a Mexican standoff.
A few hours later the French Admiral called
on nearby backup just in case the British
did decide to open fire.
But the British soon caught wind of the encroaching
backup and so the captain sent a telegram
to Number 10.
Informing Churchill of the incoming French
backup only minutes away.
Churchill was suddenly weighed down by his
worst fear, that it would have to come to
this, the possibility of ordering the British
to shoot upon their own allies.
With little time to think he sent back a short,
sharp reply “Settle matters quickly.”
and that was it, knowing full well what that
might entail.
Regrettably the British fleet knew what they
had to do next, as Churchill had briefed them
beforehand.
Yet the British signalled the French ship
once more, giving them one last warning, come
to an agreement within 30 minutes or we will
open fire.
At 5:54pm no agreement had been reached and
sure enough the British pointed their cannons
at the French vessels and began to fire.
The British fleet that day consisted of battleships
HMS Valiant and HMS Resolution, an aircraft
carrier and several destroyers.
But at the helm of the fleet was the Royal
Navy’s most powerful weapon, HMS Hood, the
largest and most powerful warship in the world
at that time, completely unmatched by any
other ship.
Her huge turrets fired relentlessly upon the
French battleships, sinking one and completely
destroying the others within minutes.
1,297 French servicemen lost their lives that
day at the hand of the British, supposedly
their closest ally.
Whilst the British public and government were
entirely supportive of Churchill’s decision
when they found out what had happened, many
others around the world, particularly the
French were both critical and upset at Britain’s
actions that day, seeing on betrayal.
It could be argued that Churchill’s move
to sink the French navy was over the top and
rash but one has to consider what the other
outcome would have been, if Hitler had got
his hands on those French battleships, it
is entirely possible that the entire world,
not just Britain, would be under Nazi rule
today.
It is reported that when word got back to
Churchill in London about what had happened
in Mers-el-Kébir and how many French servicemen
had been killed he was physically sick and
broke down in tears.
Whether you agree with operation catapult
or not no one can argue how incomprehensibly
difficult a decision of that magnitude must
have been for Churchill or any other leader
to make.
Churchill sacrificed over a thousand of Britain’s
allies that day to save the British people
and potentially the world from the tyranny
of evil, a horrible decision to make with
irreparable consequences, but if that’s
not true leadership then I don’t know what
is.
Winston Churchill was recently voted by the
British public as the greatest Briton of all
time and sure it’s tremendously easy to
see how he is great leader.
He stared pure evil in the face when the rest
of his cabinet wanted to surrender, he led
Britain and Western Europe through its darkest
hour.
He was a master of the english language and
used it to inspire and uplift the moral of
the British people.
But how come there are some leaders today
that are considered by their people as great,
when the rest of the world can only see the
opposite?
It used to be that good and evil was so black
and white, you would look at the world stage
and the vast differences between the goodies
and the baddies was laid out bare for all
to see.
But today our leaders are becoming ever more
grey, treading a thin line between good and
evil.
Leaders such as Donald Trump and Kim Jong
Un are so polarising yet so murky.
Sure leaders have always had supporters and
detractors but in today’s information driven
world it’s so easy to find out why supposedly
bad leaders do the things they do, instead
of relying on propaganda.
And with nobody is the balance between good
and evil more murkier, harder to understand
than with Vladimir Putin.
You cannot talk about great leaders without
including Putin, for nobody is more loved
by their own people.
Okay, maybe Kim Jong Un is, but under entirely
different circumstances.
Every single week an army of polsters traverses
the 11 different time zones of Russia and
knocks on the doors of every single house
in the country, asking their opinion of Vladimir
Putin and other political issues.
According to these polls Vladimir Putin’s
approval rating by his own people is a staggering
83% and has not dropped below 80% since 2014.
And these numbers aren’t superficially increased
by the Kremlin, several independent Western
polling companies have done similar polls
and always arrive around the same number.
To put that into perspective Trump’s approval
rating is half of that at 40%, Theresa May’s
is 43% and Angela Merkel’s is around 50%,
at the time of writing this video.
But how can this be?
Doesn’t most of the west view Putin as a
bad guy? Or a troublemaker at the very least.
And it’s easy to see why, Putin has done
some rather questionable and immoral things
including annexing Crimea, waging a war on
the LGBT community, he is suspected of having
critics and political enemies killed and the
most questionable act of all, he is of course
rumored to have used hacking campaigns and
propaganda to make Trump president.
But no matter how much western politicians
and western media demonises him, his approval
rating within Motherland Russia just keep
increasing with time.
To appreciate why we have to understand the
vast difference in culture between Russia
and the West.
Russians respect strength, whilst Western
Europeans may have ideals such as fair democracy,
social equality and justice, it is ingrained
within the Russian culture to never show weakness.
Russians strive for the solidification and
strengthening of their own nation.
They have a great respect for Russia and any
president who can make Russia appear to be
strong and not a pushover on the world stage
is no doubt going to be popular.
Putin does exactly that, the propaganda released
from the Kremlin is carefully curated to always
show Putin in positions of strength and in
manly pursuits like fishing topless, hunting
topless and riding a shark, I mean horse,
topless!
There seems to be a theme here.
These are not candid holiday snaps, these
are carefully curated to show Putin in his
best and strongest light.
He appears formidable and able to take on
whatever the West throws at him.
Putin may not play nicely on the global stage
but whether you sympathise with Putin’s
methods of politics or not he is in his own
way and for the Russian people at least, a
great leader.
Leaders come in many forms, throughout history
some have led us into the dark abyss, other
have led us to victory but one thing that
all great leaders do is bring about change
within the world and leave their own unique
footprint on the future, sometime for the
best, sometimes for the worst.
So wherever you are in the world, when the
time next comes for you to choose a leader,
make your choice worthwhile.
Thanks for watching.